Olá você sabia que alguns dos olhos mais
comuns da nossa alimentação podem ser
verdadeiros venenos pra nossa saúde hoje
eu vou revelar para você uma verdade
surpreendente sobre os óleos de sementes
processados E como eles podem estar
sabotando silenciosamente o seu
bem-estar então fique comigo para
descobrir como escolhas simples na
cozinha podem impactar seu corpo de
forma profunda e se você tiver paciência
e for até o final você terá acesso ao
conteúdo bos super
diferenciada A grande ilusão dos olhos
vegetais por décadas fomos levados a
acreditar que os óleos vegetais como
soja milho canola e girassol eram opções
saudáveis na alimentação no entanto a
ciência moderna tem demonstrado que
esses olhos altamente processados
altamente processados são na verdade um
dos principais vilões das doenças
crônicas modernas esses olhos passam por
processos industriais que envolvem altas
temperaturas sobre ventes químicos
alterando a sua composição natural e
introduzindo componentes altamente
prejudiciais à nossa saúde Mas então o
que são óleos de sementes processados os
óleos de sementes processados são
extraídos de sementes como soja milho
canola e girassol através de métodos que
incluem refinamento
desodorização utilização de sorvetes
químicos esse processamento não só
remove nutrientes essenciais mas também
introduz gorduras hidrogenadas que são
conhecidas por aumentar o risco de
doenças
cardiovasculares Além disso esses óleos
são ricos em ômega-6 um tipo de gordura
que em excesso quando consumido em
excesso pode promover inflamações no
nosso
organismo Então qual seria o perigo do
excesso de ômega-6 embora ômega-6 seja
essencial para o funcionamento do nosso
corpo o desequilíbrio entre ômega-6 e
ômega-3 pode levar a vários estados
inflamatórios de doenç crônicas
atualmente o consumo de ômega-6 chega a
ser 80 G por dia muito além do limite
seguro de 10 g por dia então essa
inflamação crônica está associado a
várias doenças artrite doenças cardíacas
até certos tipos de câncer a dieta
ocidental típica com alto consumo de
óleos vegetais processados contribui
significativamente para esse
desequilíbrio impactos na saúde os danos
causados pelo consumo excessivo de óleo
de semente processado são alarmantes
levam à disfunção mitocondrial que é
comprometimento do funcionamento dessa
organela tão importante na produção de
energia celular danos ao DNA aumentando
a oxidação celular inflamação crônica
através de promoção de um estado
inflamatório constante no nosso
organismo problemas na pele aumenta a
sensibilidade solar e o risco de câncer
de pele então esses impactos não apenas
afetam a saúde física mas também pode
influenciar o bem-estar mental e
qualidade de vida de maneira geral vamos
falar então das gorduras hidrogenadas e
seu risco oculto durante o processamento
dos óleos de sementes muitas vezes são
adicionadas gorduras hidrogenadas ou
parcialmente hidrogenadas para que
aumentar a durabilidade estabilidade do
produto para que aguente mais tempo na
prateleira Supermercado Então essas
gorduras trans são altamente
prejudiciais elevam os níveis de LDL
colesterol as frações ruins e reduzem o
colesterol HDL o bom aumentando o risco
de doenças cardiovasculares Além disso
as gorduras trans estão ligadas ao
aumento da resistência à insulina e
podem contribuir pro desenvolvimento do
diabetes tipo do e quais são Então as
alternativas saudáveis os olhos de
semente que são os benéficos felizmente
existem alternativas muito mais
saudáveis no universo dos óleos e
sementes e um exemplo desses é o óleo de
semente de abóbora é rico em
antioxidantes vitaminas e ácidos grassos
essenciais Esse óleo não só possui um
perfil de gordura mais equilibrada mas
também possui atividades
anti-inflamatórias que podem ajudar a
combater os efeitos negativos do excesso
de ômega-6 outros óleos saudáveis são o
óleo de oliva o azeite o óleo de abacate
e óleo de coco que são menos processados
e mantém mais nutrientes naturais Então
como fazer escolhas conscientes na
cozinha a adote hábitos alimentares mais
saudáveis isso começa com a escolha dos
ingredientes certos opte por óleos
prensados a frio e minimamente
processados que podem preservar melhor
os nutrientes e evitar a adição de
gordura trans além disso balanceia a
ingestão de ômega-6 com ômega-3 como
aumentar o consumo de peixes aumentar o
consumo de óleo ômega-3 cemente de
linhaça isso é essencial para manter a
saúde inflamatória sobre controle
pequenas mudanças Como substituir o óleo
de canola por óleo de coco o azeite de
oliva é muito bom a manteiga clarificada
manteiga Gui a banha de porco o óleo de
abacate todos eles podem trazer grande
diferença no seu bem-estar geral então
evite alimentos processados
industrializados fast food condimentos
também industrializados que é
fundamental para reduzir a ingestão
desses óleos prejudiciais então em
resumo Estar atento aos tipos de óleos
que consumimos é um passo fundamental
para Vida Saudável então evitando óleo
de sementes processados e optando por
alternativas mais naturais como óleo de
coco azeito de oliva manteiga
clarificada Gui banha de porco óleo de
abacate tudo isso pode reduzir a
inflamação e o risco de doenças crônicas
agora para vocês que ficaram até aqui
Meus parabéns vai seguir agora o
conteúdo bônus óleos extras que são
interessantes óleo de amendoim é uma
excelente alternativa devido ao seu alto
teor de gorduras monoinsaturadas que são
benéficas para a saúde cardiovascular
Além disso possui um ponto de fumaça
elevado então torna ele ideal para
cozinhar em altas temperaturas sem a
formação de compostos nocivos o óleo de
dendê ou óleo de palma ele é rico em
antioxidantes como a vitamina E e
betacaroteno no entanto é importante
você optar por versões não refinadas e
sustentáveis para evitar impactos
ambientais e garantir que o óleo de
palma ou de dender mantenha os seus
nutrientes naturais
óleo de gelim e tahine o óleo de gelim é
conhecido por suas propriedades
antiinflamatórias e também antioxidantes
graças a compostos chamados lignanos é a
sesamina e o sesamol já o tahine que é
uma pasta feita a partir de sementes e
gelim moídas é uma fonte rica de
proteínas vitaminas e minerais e ambos
os produtos são excelentes para
adicionar Sabor e nutrientes saudáveis à
suas refeições sem os efeitos
prejudiciais dos óleos processados óleo
de linhaça é uma das melhores fontes de
ômega-3 vegetal essencial para a saúde
do coração e do cérebro rico em lignanas
antioxidantes ajuda a reduzir inflamação
e pode até contribuir pra prevenção de
certos tipos de câncer especialmente
intestino grosso óleo de semente de chia
outro top é semelhante ao óleo de
linhaça ele também vai oferecer uma
abundância de ômega-3 também a atividade
antioxidante tem fibras é perfeito para
adicionar as smfs as saladas e promove a
saúde cardiovascular e a saúde da pele o
óleo de semente de cânhamo que é pouco
conhecido no Brasil tem uma proporção
equilibrada de omega6 para omega3 esse
óleo de cemente de cimo é ideal para
reduzir a inflamação promover a saúde
geral rico também em vitamina E e
minerais e beneficia a saúde da pele
quando aplicado diretamente sobre ela se
você dar de sa ou é uma pessoa mais
avançada nos estudos eu vou colocar aqui
um link para uma aula mais completa
sobre esse assunto que vai estar no meu
canal alternativo então o link vai estar
na descrição e primeiro comentário Que
tal começar hoje mesmo a revisar sua
dispensa e fazer escolhas mais
conscientes mais saudáveis a sua saúde
vai te agradecer nos próximos anos Muito
obrigado pela sua atenção você é fera um
grande abraço e um beijo no seu coração
vídeos faço bem a vida de alguém pode
mudar também no canal do T além do TR se
vvar